bonsoir Monsieur fit Keven alors cette
journée c'est une journée 80
spécialistes il va y avoir des mémoires
il va y avoir les consultations vont se
poursuivre les spécialistes nous parlent
souvent ici sur ce plateau d'efficacité
énergétique de l'importance de
l'efficacité énergétique est-ce qu'on
vous parle beaucoup de ça et de
modulation tarifaire également beaucoup
aujourd'hui en fait c'est le lancement
de la consultation comme vous avez dit
il y avait trois chantiers qu'on a
regardé le premier c'est la demande et
l'offre comment on va balancer un bilan
qui est très serré présentement la
tarification qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
on doit faire la question de gouvernance
quand on parle la demande et l'offre
évidemment on va commencer par l'énergie
qui est la moins dispendieuse c'est
celle que nous consommons pas alors
madame brochure son départ avait hier je
suis suicide vous rappeler la V8
on pouvait aller chercher 25 terwatters
d'efficacité énergétique et aujourd'hui
des gens qui m'ont dit avant d'arriver
ici pourquoi on va pas à 40 pourquoi on
va pas 50 alors je pense que pour moi
d'écouter les experts nous expliquer
comment on pourrait réduire surtout en
puissance ou en énergie de conseils
différents comment on se demande ça va
être moins d'énergie qu'on va avoir
besoin pour le futur par ça si on va à
40 ou à 50 on le fait comment on module
les tarifs non on peut faire semer des
choses comme le code des bâtiments on va
regarder quelque chose comme les
bactéries de voitures bidirectionnelles
il y a un péchés il y a des nouvelles
technologies qui vont être mises en
place pourquoi pas financer des termes
aux pompes pour les résidences pour
avoir un chauffage coefficient il y a
déjà des des rabais qui existent comme
ça de toute façon mais c'est pas assez
structurant donc faut en faire plus plus
de rebelles sur les thermopompes sur les
fenêtres qu'on achète pour isoler notre
maison que ce soit il connaît
énergétique ou et d'une part et je pense
il faut mieux communiquer il faut
accepter qu'au Québec c'est récent de
parler d'un bilan énergétique serré tu
es vraiment là on avait des surplus avec
les vidéos électriques alors surplus bon
alors je consomme là je pense pour faire
un meilleur travail comme gouvernement
et au Québec à population
on manque pas d'électricité pour
chauffer les ménages c'est clair l'année
prochaine 30-40 ans danger pour leur
danger qu'on manque d'électricité pour
des projets structuraux
les gens réalisent ça la richesse
collective la décarbonation du Québec
c'est important aussi deux mesures là
font en sorte qu'il faut augmenter
l'oeuf et bien ça demande exactement
mais c'est la demande ça peut
fonctionner si les tarifs sont plus
élevés en économie vous montez un tarif
pour pour faire en sorte que les gens
changent de comportement vous avez dit
clairement fin de semaine vous voulez
pas monter les tarifs d'électricité à ce
moment aussi non parce que je pense les
Québécois sont pas prêts à ça par contre
ce qu'on a dit monsieur Legault on peut
peut-être avoir des incitatifs plus
grands pour une consommation différente
alors on peut même envisager en pointe
on peut même envisager de réduire les
factures d'exercices parce que l'enjeu
c'est pas de faire plus de revenus
l'enjeu c'est qu'on veut réduire la
demande dans les points et même hors des
pointes alors je pense qu'on peut faire
ça en communiquant technologie et
peut-être avoir des initiatives
financiers pour consommer différemment
je veux juste être clair comprendre
clairement vous dites à ce moment-ci on
ne manquera pas les tarifs d'électricité
mais ça pourrait venir éventuellement
dans une idée de modulaire modulation
tarifaire
nous ne voulons pas toucher à la
tarification parce que je pense que
c'est c'est les Québécois assume ça puis
il faut comprendre aussi on oublie
souvent dire que les industries souvent
les industries les industries
subventionnelles de résidentiel parce
que nos taux résidentiel
pour être beaucoup plus élevé si on
regarde les coûts et ses industries qui
les finances il faut faire attention
aussi mais on va maintenir ce
déséquilibre là qu'on appelle
l'interfinancement on va le maintenir
parce qu'on a d'autres moyens nous
pensons pour réduire de consommation
des industries pas de hausse de tarifs
pour les entreprises on va voir au sens
large on va voir la tarification
c'est pas juste on augmente
la tarification c'est par exemple une
entreprise qui est prêt à s'effacer du
système quand tout est en point sur une
très grande valeur à prix au Québec
alors il y a des mesures comme ça qu'on
va regarder les vidéos Québec on oublie
souvent exporte beaucoup d'électricité
exportent 37 TER cette année des
contrats alors comment on peut prendre
cette énergie là la conserver au Québec
mais on parle de stockage stockage c'est
plus complexe mais il y a beaucoup de
technologie qu'on doit évaluer donc
exporter plus là on n'est pas là-dedans
là on n'est plus là-dedans on est plus
dans dans la signature de gros contrat
avec les Américains
de New York par exemple c'est un bon
contrat on peut argument qu'on aurait dû
garder terrawacs la raison qu'on le fait
donc avec le fait c'est une bonne raison
on a un réseau intégré donc on peut
importer et exporter plus facilement
donc ce parfait mon on va arrêter là il
y a quelques jours vous avez dit il y a
1000 mégawatts de disponible en ce
moment puis on a des demandes de projet
pour 21000 mégawatts donc les
entreprises les Volkswagen de ce monde
doivent attendre un peu là pour être
capable de voir des mégawatts au Québec
20 000 mégawatts c'est 13 remède alors
au-delà des questions énergétique faut
construire faut développer faut faire
des barrages bon vous pouvez m'enlever
21 mai c'est une demande que nous avons
reçu avec le ministère on identifie
de projets que je pense qu'on doit faire
aujourd'hui effectivement de chez
femelle durant un plus bas au moment où
on se parle je vais annoncer des refus
de connexion au mode juillet
probablement sauf que les gens qui ont
des projets structuraux réponse est non
on peut pas oui on peut ou non mais moi
je travaille fortement avec les gros
joueurs industriels filières batteries
entrepôt dire
2027 c'est trop tôt peut-être 2028 2029
vous avez vu on a fait des appels
d'offres les éoliens ils vont être
connecté très rapidement donc on est
capable je pense la traite du Québec
est-elle qu'on peut probable moduler
dire au gros utilisateurs attendez un
petit peu on va vous donner
progressivement vos mégawatts avec
l'énergie renouvelable comme l'éolien
comme le soleil éventuellement mais ce
qu'on va jusqu'au barrage monsieur
faitquier
si on veut débarras une chose qui est
sorti clairement dans le aujourd'hui que
j'ai beaucoup aimé c'est la question de
planification des ressources alors faut
planifier sur une base de 10 ans
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des gaz naturel
question très importante alors
2050 c'est pas demain matin puis les
gars naturels au Québec on a consomme
l'équivalent de 17000 MW ça c'est 17
barges demain on dit plus
naturellement alors faut regarder
l'offre disponible par plus on va
réduire la demande moins il va avoir
besoin d'oeuf c'est sa première chose
l'offre est allié moi je pense qu'on va
mettre 10 12
au niveau des municipalités pas de
transport directement dans l'édifice les
turbines sont vieilles il faut les
changer c'est 2000 mégawatts
qu'on a l'huile pyrolytique on peut
faire du biochambon du biocarbonate pour
permettre aux entreprises de se
décarboner aussi sans prendre
l'électricité franchement il faut tout
regarder ça à la fin est-ce qu'il va
manquer peut-être
donc c'est une réflexion plusieurs
années que vous me donnez faut faire
quels sont les besoins
PDG nouvelle PDG nouveau PDG c'est pour
quand de l'Hydro-Québec
je vais respecter mon engagement donc
6 - 4 2 donc si le 30 mai nouvelle
personne
copier les gens ont des emplois faut
faire des choses dans l'ordre alors on
espère l'annoncerez pas c'est qui non
une femme ou un homme
merci Monsieur merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]